let's jump into the stuff about the uh
the shoving trial specifically
because this is the kind of this is the
kind of stuff that
freaks me out thenation.com
one of the premier leftist publications
i mean they've been around for a long
time
they got an article that says the
acquittal of derek chauvin has already
begun
what i agree i think he will be
acquitted i don't know for sure
don't take my word for it if i had to
put 10 bucks down i'd say 10 bucks on
acquittal that's just me
i'm not saying i'd make a real bet i
wouldn't because i don't know but the
nation agrees the left agrees
many on the right think he's not going
to be convicted and they have this
really really great passage
let me just read this uh paragraph for
you they say chauvin's trial started
this week
and soon a jury comprised mainly of
white people
of this we can be almost certain will
tell us whether they think killing a
black man should be a crime
in a reasonable world this trial would
be perfunctory
hell in a reasonable world there
wouldn't even be
a trial wow uh i'm going to make a small
wager that he had to look up or she had
to look up what perfunctory meant
that's very pompous however there's more
chauvin would have accepted some kind of
plea deal that's what most people do
when they are caught on camera killing
someone
so they're not saying outright banned
trials
however this sentiment is echoed by
chelsea handler who in my opinion
probably read that article
because newsweek.com reports chelsea
handler sparks backlash for suggesting
trials be skipped
when there's video evidence to to look
to an ignorant person they're gonna go
uh there's literally video of it what's
the point of a trial if we all watched
it happen well to those people on the
ignorant level
even if chauvin's body killed the other
guy's body
uh what's his name i don't know floyd
george say his name
is their name or if one body kills
another you still have to determine the
intention
that's what the trial would be for if
anything to figure out the intention
right that's the guy but they're even
trying to figure out the whole situation
they want to go deeper they want to find
out
what's going on on fentanyl and out of
his mind and on his way
no that we know for sure when you're
right we know because the tax report and
things like that
the issue is breaking down all the facts
having a debate
an argument a trial over what chauvin
did and whether or not it was reasonable
whether or not as you mentioned intent
so when you have these
low information individuals left as tour
like there wouldn't even be a trial you
should take a plea and then chelsea
handler saying we should skip the trial
we saw it on video
that's a scary reality man how many
followers does chelsea handler have
yeah don't ever make those jokes on
twitter she's influencing a lot of
people
and this is where we're at right now so
when i see this stuff and i see a story
that when you look at all the details
from a rational point of view
the minneapolis police department and
this is evidence put out by the defense
and there's a photo of this
trained the police to use the particular
restraint that chauvin did why
because if you put your knee on
someone's back you can cause
a you can cause asphyxiation so they
move the knee to the neck so that their
chest can still
move up and down they can still breathe
apparently that's why
chauvin did that he was trained to do it
they also have all these witnesses who
said they were yelling at him you're
going to kill him and these things
you think he could hear every single
person screaming at him at the same time
he has no idea what's going on now
if you want to have a conversation about
manslaughter we've long suggested
there's a real argument there
that's why a trial must be had to get to
the bottom of this you know the craziest
thing about all this is
i'm almost swearing at these people we
put the nazis on trial
we literally put nazis on trial
nuremberg yes we were like we want them
to stand trial why
because even if you can prove it beyond
a reasonable doubt and everyone's seen
the evidence
you want to present it in a legal court
so it can be in the record
legitimate verbatim legacy history boom
there's the records it happened do you
think chelsea said that uh when trump
got impeached they should just skip the
trial and throw him right out
probably not skip the trial no trials
you know this is just a continuation of
the degradation of due process that
we've seen across the country
title ix regulations totally stripped
men and people accused of sexual
harassment sexual assault of their due
process
donald trump fixed it joe biden is
trying to turn it back
they don't want due process they saw a
video a girl
said it believe all women if kavanaugh
had the same treatment that chelsea
handler is suggesting
kavanaugh would never be a supreme court
justice because he'd be in jail because
a woman said that the
guy you know they they uh you know group
raped him or whatever did you
did you see that new york times article
about smith college
where it was the black student who was
in the closed dorm room
so so for those of us don't know the
story there's a black student
she was in a dorm that was closed a
janitor was told if you see anybody in
the building
call campus security or police because
there's not supposed to be anybody here
apparently she had an arrangement where
she was allowed to be there but the
janitor didn't know so he called and
said hey there's somebody here
the cop came up walked up to her and
said hey how's it going
uh what what's going on oh you're
cheating oh okay no problem sorry for
bothering you how's your day going all
right have a nice day that was it
she then makes this video where she was
like someone called the cops on me for
just eating and you know and being black
when in reality it was that somebody was
told to call the cops if that was the
case
and an independent review found there
was nothing wrong but hold on this is
the important point
the new york times wrote that her
was what did they say they said this
student's
personal personal truth was at odds with
the facts
they were like a shocking moment for for
a student whose personal truth was at
odds with the facts
that's called being wrong but the way
they're framing it now is that
we all have our personal truth our lived
experience
standpoint theory call that perception
and everyone has a different
this sounds like the same thing that
happened to aoc when she was not in the
capitol building but a cop came in to be
like hey what are you doing you got to
get out of here but like an hour before
anyone went into the building anyway
amazing it was that was that was
apparently because there was a bomb
scare
and aoc makes this story man it's so
obvious she's lying to anybody who
followed the news but i see so many
people who just don't know and they
believe it
i was even talking to a huffington post
journalist who was like your timeline's
wrong aoc
blah blah and so i started researching
and i'm like yo a full
hour before anyone breached any part of
this building
any part of it and before they were even
fighting with the cops i think they had
just started scuffling
the cop was clearing out a different
building because of a potential bomb
scare
and everybody went back because nobody
ever went in those buildings
the story she told was very much as
though
she was in the capital and people were
looking for she lied she was like i'm
like
they got in they're going to find me and
i thought i was going to die or whatever
it's like
nobody got in any building why would you
be thinking that before literally anyone
any of this happened because she's lying
because they're lived experienced
i love this meme it's uh you know the
winnie the pooh meme
where it's like winnie the pooh sitting
down then he's got a monocle that he's
wearing a full tux
it's like getting fancier it's like the
first one says my opinion
and it's regular winnie the pooh the
next one is he's got a monocle that says
anecdotal evidence and then the tuxedo
says my lived experience
that's exactly what it is they want
lived experience in this notion is part
of
radical feminism critical race theory
it's embedded
in their entire philosophy their
philosophy of activism and change
and so if crt continues its march
through its institutions
if it continues its march through the
legislative process through its
bureaucracies
due process is gone fact is gone the
only thing that will matter
is people's personal truths if you're
the right person
i don't think my personal truth is going
to matter much yeah you know
so uh before we do this show sometimes
i'll either watch
star trek the next generation if it's on
but to date with sliders you guys are
watching
the show oh my god dude from the 80s
were they changed were they
in the late 90s whatever i mean look to
me that's all they say
i watch late 90s shows that's why i'm
watching
outer limits and mid 90s star technology
sliders this is where they like
time traveling no no no no no the actor
jerry's something oh dimensions
dimensional travel the episode today was
they they go to a direction
they go to a dimension where it's a
religious takeover
it was fascinating to watch this is this
is really relevant to everybody okay
listen to this
sliders is the late it's 1998 i think
was the year i'm not entirely sure
and they go to this reality where
everyone is a believer
in this essentially mockery of like
christianity right
and there's a point in the show where
they say wow
you know this is a a reality or a
government that's all about tradition
family values and faith and spirituality
and then one of the characters from
earth prime which is ours he goes
we had we had politicians who wanted to
implement those same kind of laws in our
in our earth but
i guess this is what it would be like if
they won it's funny
but watching it i was like it's actually
more like critical race theory
i don't think it matters what the
religion is when i when when ideological
moral authoritarians take over
it looks the same so watching this it
was very much from the perspective of
people who practice science were
demonized and criminalized and the
religion was paramount
and you know they would arrest you if
you admitted you did science or if you
didn't have your ids and stuff like that
but i'm like that analogy makes more
sense
in terms of cancel culture and critical
race theory than it does to christianity
or any religion right now
in the united states like they don't
believe in science
although in this instance they claim to
believe in signs when they literally
don't
and if you believe the wrong thing
they'll cancel you they'll cancel you
for any reason
the scary thing about totalitarianism
and authoritarianism
is that there is nothing you can do even
if you follow the rules
you are expendable you are like
the fingernails to be clipped and the
thing about science is nice is if a new
idea
appears you don't smash it out and
destroy it like you would in
without a trial person or something you
put it on trial a new idea goes on trial
that's the scientific method
and you test it and that's why it's
better than religion
or otherwise better than religion in the
16th century when they would murder
people and burn him at the stake for
suggesting that the
earth revolved around the sun i am not
going to sit here i am no
no no no no no hold on i'm not going to
sit here and listen to
your white supremacy i truly believe
it's scientists
not about supremacy science well you
have a point
how do you they said that they said he's
going to take it modern science people
in the audience were like are they
really fighting
no no they said the critical race theirs
believe modern science and the idea of
objectivity is racist
white supremacy so your ideas about
going on trial and challenging ideas
we all agree on that the scientific
method they're not perfect dude i do
agree
specifically stated in their literature
that a reliance on data
is white supremacy yeah you don't want
to be obsessive you don't want to rely
on data to your death
there is points where data can be wrong
and the irony that i experienced as
working in the charter school industry
and working at the a regulator that
that oversaw like 60 charter schools in
dc was that they kept saying over and
over again we're data driven data driven
data driven which they need to be right
you like
you like study you know how where the
kids are failing
so that you can drill down and like
reinforce stuff data driven data driven
data driven
but then they start bringing in the crt
stuff and all the crt stuff is like
reliance on data white supremacy
reliance on science
white supremacy reliance on objectivity
white supremacy
and so at the same time as they're
preaching data data-driven
analytics data-driven education they're
starting to slide that out and be like
oh the achievement gap
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you